even die hard mortal kombat fans are
likely to miss some of the details
included in the latest live-action movie
these are the easter eggs you may have
missed from series standbys like blue
kang and sonia blade to more obscure
fighters
such as natara and reiko mortal kombat
manages to incorporate a wide array of
characters from the long-running game
series
and that's only to mention those who
actually appear in the film
if you pay close attention you'll notice
that even more characters get referenced
throughout the movie
even though they aren't seen on screen
early on sonia shows carl juncker
research on the mortal kombat tournament
and outworld one of the documents has a
page from a book that includes an
illustration of a native american man
with the caption matoka warrior
the person in the illustration looks
remarkably like nightwolf
a fighter introduced immortal combat 3
who's a member of the fictional matoka
tribe
sonia's research also includes an image
of what appears to be an aztec burst
which could be a nod to kotal khan
mortal kombat x introduced the
intimidating character
whose design draws some obvious
inspiration from aztec culture
elsewhere in the movie character's name
dropped xiao khan the brutal emperor of
outworld
as well as bo wright show the martial
arts grandmaster who trains liu kang
raiden's temple also contains a couple
of visual nodes to unseen characters
the signature fan blades of the adenium
princess katana
can be seen displayed in one of the
temple's corridors and one crucial scene
sees kano stealing an item that looks
very similar to the amulet of shinnok
the appropriately named magical talisman
in question belongs to shinnok
an elder god who first appeared in
mortal kombat 4.
not only does the new mortal kombat
movie make numerous references to
characters who don't even appear in the
film
but it also pushes things even further
by paying homage to the series creators
we get our first taste of this when jax
introduces himself to cole young
jax mentions a past fight where coal
managed to take the belt away from a
fighter named eddie tobias
a subtle nod to mortal kombat
co-creators ed boone and john tobias
tobias is responsible for much of the
original character design
lore and world building of the early
games additionally the movie honors the
mortal kombat franchise's real home
chicago when cole's relation to scorpion
is revealed the protagonist finds it
hard to believe
he considers himself just a kid from the
south side of chicago
the windy city was a home of original
mortal kombat developer midway games
which was also responsible for other
arcade hits like rampage and nba jam
midway games filed for bankruptcy in
2009.
warner brothers bought the mortal kombat
iep that same year
chicago can still claim mortal kombat
because netherrealm studios the studio
responsible for the current crop of
games in the franchise
is based in the city colors play a huge
role in mortal kombat
especially the older games in the series
much of the ninja characters like
scorpion sub-zero
and rain were different from each other
visually thanks to the primary colours
used in their design
it only makes sense for the new movie to
play around with this concept in its own
unique way
when we're first introduced to carl jung
he's seen prepping his hands for an mma
fight
wrapping them in yellow tape this is a
reference to scorpion and his clan
the shirai ryu whose main color is
yellow it's also an early hint that coal
is somehow related to the clan and
scorpion there's even a spot of yellow
on the strap of his gym bag
not to be outdone by his rival sub-zero
also provides us with a major visual
clue
that hints at his ultimate fate during
his final battle with scorpion and cole
the ice-cold assassin gets rid of the
blue parts of his outfit
showing himself in complete black this
is a reference to the super dark noob
cybot
a character that the first sub-zero
bihan later becomes after being killed
by scorpion in the games
noob cybot is a play on the reverse last
names of ed boon and john tobias
the character was introduced in the
series thanks to boone immortal combat
2.
however noob sidebot was so secret a
character that not even boone's partner
tobias knew about him at first
tobias was already a few months into
development on mortal kombat 3 before he
learned about the secret character's
existence
a mortal kombat movie wouldn't be
considered authentic without the iconic
techno theme
that has become associated with the
series fortunately there are two scenes
in the new film where bits of it can be
heard
when liu kang launches his trademark
bicycle kick against cabal
a few familiar notes play in the
background it's subtle especially
compared to when the theme makes its
second appearance
during the film's conclusive stretch
when scorpion finally appears to face
sub-zero in their ensuing battle
the theme returns this time booming in
an impressive remix the mortal kombat
theme is officially called techno
syndrome
created by belgian duo the immortals
also known as maurice prager khan
angelon and oliver adams the two are
also known for their work from the group
lords of acid midway games contacted
angeline and adams about making an album
to go along with the 1994 home console
release of the hit arcade game
while between tours the two got to work
producing the entire record in four
weeks
mortal kombat the album featured songs
based on the original roster of
characters
but it was techno syndrome that became
the defining hit it went on to be used
in commercials
movies and just about anything the
series has dipped its brutal hands in
for the soundtrack of the 2021 movie
composer benjamin wolfish gave the theme
a new edm tinged feel
early on in the film sonia fills coal in
on the legend of the mortal kombat
tournament
by showing him a collection of newspaper
clippings and other research materials
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament one
obscured headline includes the text
storm causes panic
although the first word is mostly cut
away it seems possible that the whole
phrase is meant to read lightning storm
causes panic
considering it's on sonia's wall of
research that could be a reference to
lord raiden
who arrives in earth realm via an
intense series of lightning strikes on
multiple occasions
the headline could be describing what
radiant strikes looked like to normal
earth dwellers who were unaware that
they were witnessing the approach of the
god of thunder
similarly another incomplete headline
ends with breaking hailstorm
presumably it's meant to say
record-breaking hailstorm which could be
a reference to sub-zero
earlier in the movie he arrived in earth
realm and manifested a fierce ice storm
while attempting to kill cole
could he have done something similar at
another time leading to people confusing
his supernatural powers for an extra
intense weather event
mortal kombat is a game series that
isn't afraid to make changes to its own
canon
for instance the ninth title in the
franchise also titled mortal kombat
was a reboot for the series and made
some key changes in the stories of the
first three games
the new movie is just as happy to play
around with established lore
whether it be kano teaming up with the
heroes or introducing a completely new
protagonist to the fault but things get
a little ridiculous when it comes to
jackson how he loses his arms
sub-zero is the one to take away jax's
human arms in the new movie
but this is only the latest in a variety
of unfortunate ways
jax has lost his arms in the game series
in the ninth game
jack says his arms exploded when irmak
uses his telekinetic powers
in the web series mortal kombat legacy
grenades destroy jax's arms
and in the animated mortal kombat
legends scorpion's revenge
goro just completely rips them off let's
hope that the next retelling of how
jax loses his arms is kinder to the
special forces soldier
mortal kombat more than earned it's our
rating thanks to the graphic fatalities
that conclude many of the brawls in the
movie
in fact the film actually recreates
several of the iconic finishing moves
from the game franchise
early in the movie an encounter between
kano and reptile
ends with kano reaching into the
creature's chest and ripping out its
heart
the same move was used as kano's
fatality in the very first mortal kombat
game
similarly the fire-breathing finisher
that scorpion pulls on sub-zero
is a throwback to the original game two
of the movie's glorious moments also
come directly from the source material
kung lao's hat is a butt of quite a few
jokes throughout the film
but he proves its brutal utility when he
quickly ends an encounter with the
winged natara
by turning the bladed headwear into a
buzzsaw and feeding her into it
a version of this particularly gruesome
fatality was first used in the spin-off
game
mortal kombat shaolin monks and has gone
on to become a mainstay of kung lao's
repertoire
in the main series meanwhile jax gets
the chance to test out his new arcana
powered metal arms
while fighting reiko after beating shang
tsung's lackey to his knees
jax claps his hands on raikko's head
bursting it like a melon
this move was one of jax's first
fatalities when the character made his
debut in mortal kombat 2.
lucan gets an opportunity to show off
his impressive arcana power as well
summoning a giant dragon made of fire to
fatally burn cabal
this is a variation of lukang's dragon
transformation fatality
that he first started using in the
franchise's second installment
longtime fans of the franchise are no
doubt going to be thrilled that mortal
kombat is full of small references
to the particulars of the video games
take for instance kung lao's words of
encouragement to cole and kano when they
begin their training
all you can do now is test your might
this is a nod to the first game in the
series
which featured a mini game called test
your might it tasked players with
mashing buttons to make their character
chop through piles of material ranging
from planks of wood to a block of pure
diamond
the filmmakers also managed to
incorporate other bits of now iconic
dialogue
players would regularly hear from the
game's announcer at the end of matches
several of the fight scenes in the movie
conclude with the characters saying
things like
flawless victory and fatality after he
defeats reptile kano even giddily
announced
kind of wins these references aren't
just relegated to dialogue
the set design of mortal kombat draws
some inspiration from the levels of the
games
specifically the iconic stage known as
the pit
there have been several versions of this
arena throughout the franchise
but the basic gist is always the same
the combatants fight on a bridge
overlooking a pit of razor sharp spikes
a version of this concept appears late
in the movie when jax squares off
against ryko
fatalities aren't the only moves from
the mortal combat games that pop up in
the film
cole spirited daughter emily frequently
tells her father to use an uppercut
during his fights a punch that has been
ubiquitous for nearly every character in
the series
starting with the first game during a
2016 interview with game informer
series co-creator ed boone even said
that nailing the uppercut was integral
in the development of the first game
he recalled the big thing was the
suffocate once we got this uppercut
going
suddenly everybody is coming into my
office ah let me see the game
another frequently used maneuver from
the original games i got a special call
out in the movie
is the leg sweep and what appears to be
a nod to players who'd love to spam the
move in order to score an easy victory
liu kang leg sweeps kano several times
during one of their training sessions
after kano successfully hops over one of
the sweeps liu kang then fakes him out
before getting in with another one
this will no doubt feel familiar to
anyone who has thrown their controller
in frustration
because their friend wouldn't stop using
the move and of course many of the
characters get a chance to show off
their special abilities
lu kang gets his fireballs kano has his
laser eye and even sonia's pink energy
rings make an appearance
when the characters got revealed for the
latest mortal kombat movie
we all had one burning question where is
johnny cage
mortal kombat producer todd ghana
announced the sad news that the
character wouldn't appear in the film
but gave hope of his appearance in a
potential sequel and now a huge easter
egg has ignited our hopes for cage's
return
to the big screen the movie ends with
shang tsung's evil crew defeated
but raiden has requested that our heroes
seek out new defenders for earthrealm
as cole leaves his mma gym on this
mission from the thunder guard
he reveals that his search has taken him
to hollywood we then get an image of a
poster for a movie titled citizen cage
starring actor turned combatant johnny
cage johnny cage is a staple character
for the game series
and even shares the spotlight with his
daughter cassie cage
immortal combat x and mortal kombat 11.
with such a big personality and his
trademark split punch
johnny is unsurprisingly modeled after a
real hollywood action star
jean-claude van damme the minds behind
the ip wanted van dam to be in what
eventually became mortal combat
but he wasn't interested thus ed boon
and john tobias forged ahead
the project turned into mortal kombat
and johnny cage was born
fatality check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more luba
videos about mortal kombat are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one